[Music]  many of you know that dr. Phil's son  Jordan is a musician well last night his  van hundred handed celebrated the  release of their new song five which is  available today and Jordans proud  parents joined the party bye everybody  he's on tour so much we don't get to see  them very much so this is terrific for  us  what we wrote vibe it was the kind of  the turning point for wouldn't we  figured out what exactly we wanted to  sound like he just loves music just born  with it I guess  yeah we certainly weren't so all in one  cue  I can't even play a radio unless it's  got a big on/off button on it I mean  it's you'd get it from me I'll tell you  [Music]  you